[Music]
I'm going to talk about the motions
today and I'm gonna start by showing you
this picture and because I want to
highlight to highlight how how
remarkable is our ability to recognize
emotions our human ability to recognize
emotions so when you look at this image
for instance we don't know anything
about these people but we can capture a
lot of things about the atmosphere right
we see like a positive atmosphere and
these people seem to be engaged and seem
to be connecting on something so all of
that is emotional information that we
can capture just with one image and we
have this remarkable capacity for
recognizing emotions where is this
capacity useful for us and it's very
important in our social interactions so
we when we interact with people we are
constantly making guesses about how
others feel in order to adapt the way we
communicate to others emotions it's very
important to detect people needs as well
and also to predict people's reactions
and actually emotions are so important
in our lives and have a strong influence
in a lot of our cognitive processes so
for instance they and they modulate our
attention mechanisms and they strongly
influence our memory and also our length
learning process so emotions are so
important in our lives and when we
imagine the AI of the future so I'm
gonna ask how many of you have seen at
least one of these movies here so most
of you have seen at least one of these
movies so you know what I send on and
I'm not gonna make any spoiler but you
know what I'm say when i when when i'm
what i'm saying when i say that the
machines that we imagine in the future
all of them have some kind of emotional
intelligence but on the other side
emotions are so complex right and even
for us sometimes it's difficult to know
how others feel we can grab some
information about the upper and
emotional states of people but it's
complex sometimes to know how others
feel or even how we feel
so how can machines do something that
complex well the thing is that when our
emotions change there are a lot of
things that change in our body so for
instance when we are nervous usually our
heart rate increases our also our
respiration rate increases and we sweat
so and that the electrodermal activity
in our skin also changes our facial
expression changes our gaze patterns
change our pupil M changes as well and
our blood pressure and we have different
body postures we use different gestures
depending on how we feel our boys can
change as well the way we write the way
we type in our phones for instance so
there are a lot of signals that change
with our emotions so what we can do is
all of these signals can be captured
with different types of sensors and then
we capture the signals and if we have
data a label data with emotions what we
can do is we can try to find pattern in
the patterns in these signals that
correlate with emotions and develop
machine learning algorithms or systems
that can't recognize the emotions using
this type of information the same way we
process other type of information I'm
gonna focus first on them on so I'm
gonna talk about some examples of how
can we capture this emotional
information and I'm gonna start with
with vision modality which is one of my
areas of expertise so visual modality
cameras and what has been done so far
for recognizing emotions from
information captured by cameras any idea
what's the most popular research from a
computer vision perspective to recognize
emotions
maybe from exactly so facial expression
is actually the most common approach to
recognize emotions so when I was doing
my PhD I finished like 10 years ago now
and this was a completely unsolved
problem so I was working a little bit in
this type of software trying to
recognize keep on in the faces working
with images acquired under controlled
environments and nothing was working by
them so now after 10 years we have these
softwares that work very well in
recognizing some of the key points on
your face tracking these key points and
doing some matching between the emotions
so that the expressions that are
observed and the possible emotions that
that they are expressing and this is an
example of our commercial software from
a company called Affectiva where you see
that the software detects your key
points analyzes the configuration and
make some kind of correspondence between
this expression and the possible emotion
that you are expressing with a facial
expression and this software works very
well so it's very well at that they are
detecting the patterns is very well at
detecting the key points it's it's
complicated to associate the correct
emotion to an expression an expression
and a phase expression but and it works
pretty well in some applications it's
being used for these users for instance
but the problem of this software is that
it does not work in the wild so we would
like to have machines that can recognize
emotions in any condition so if we go
back to this to this image that I showed
you before what happens when we run this
type of software's here so if we run
this type of commercial software we can
detect very well the face of this woman
we can detect the key points and this
software is answering in this case that
this woman is feeling happiness because
it detects a smile with a strong
confidence in the text attention I don't
know exactly how this detection of
attention works here but actually it's
pretty accurate but what happens with
him so what happens with him is that the
system is not working so here we have a
problem and it's
it's all the key points of the face are
not actually visible so we have a strong
occlusions and in highlights because of
the glasses of the person and also we
have a profile view so it's not a
frontal view anymore where everything is
visible right so this type of software's
when you run them in open in open
environments you face that when you have
non frontal faces and pressure lock
partial occlusions they might not work
as well as we would like more problem so
here we have another example here is a
face and if we run the software it says
you see surprise the mouth is open so
it's detecting perfectly well a very
prototypical expression of surprise but
when we look at the context we realize
that it's not surprised right so the
thing is that this this kid and we see a
facial expression here but has nothing
to do with the emotion it's related to
the action he is performing so some of
our facial expressions have nothing to
do with our emotions but with other
things for instance when you talk you
change a lot your facial expression it
has nothing to do with your emotion and
another difficulty is giving the correct
emotional meaning to an isolated facial
expression so I'm gonna show you some
experiments some examples of experiments
that were were performed by
psychologists that were studying how how
what's the level of agreement in giving
an emotional label to a specific facial
expression like here so here we see
clearly a facial expression but if I ask
you what what's this facial expression
communicating well you might think maybe
anger may be contemned these guys fear
so usually people agree that did that
this is a negative valence emotion but
it's not clear what category the thing
is that if I give you some context
suddenly we probably will agree that
this is disgust and this is what happens
people agree here that the face is
disgust
but if you give you a different context
then people strongly agree that this is
anger so and they have a lot of examples
and they run a lot of experiments in
using the exact say
facial expression in different context
is to and they realize that the context
strongly influenced the way we perceive
emotions so this is the motivation of
one of the projects I'm working on that
started here in Barcelona and now I'm
still working on it in collaboration
with the affective computing group at
MIT Media Lab and the idea behind this
project is okay we know there's a lot of
information in the face that's true but
for for developing machines that
accurately recognize emotions we can
adjust rely and relay on the face we
need to understand the context of the
person and in particularly we are
working in the same context in the
situation of the person and the
interesting thing of working in this
type of context is that suddenly you can
say much more about the emotion so maybe
with the expression you can say
something out basic emotions but there
are some secondary emotions or social
emotions that are very interesting that
if you don't see the context you can not
say anything about them like here once
you see the context you might say that
this person is feeling confidence when
you define confidence as feeling of
being certain conviction that an outcome
will be favorable encouraged or proud so
that idea of the emotion recognition in
context projects so what we want to do
is we want to go from images like this
one so not just relying on the face and
looking also at the context of the
person trying to recognize emotions and
for that so this is a computer vision
project we know that in computer vision
nowadays what is working best is deep
learning models so our idea was ok let's
try to model this problem using deep
learning so first challenge that we
faced we didn't have any training data
of course because as we said before
usually although all the research on
emotion recognition from images was
focused on the face so we didn't have
any data set where we could see people
in their context so we were collecting a
lot of images some of them were manually
manually downloaded from from a search
engines like Google and other images
came from public datasets that were
already labeled with the width bounding
box of the person and the images we
collected are images like the ones that
you see here so people
doing different things in very different
situations and what we did is we created
annotation interfaces like this one that
I'm showing you here so where we asked
annotators to label what emotion
category they thought this person was
expressing in this specific situation
and we had we had two different two
different interfaces this is the one of
emotion categories and we have another
one for continuous dimension so there
are different ways of representing
emotions in a machine content categories
is one of the most common and emotional
dimensions is the other one and maybe
it's less popular but the idea of the a
of the continuous dimensions is to label
according to valence which is a
dimension that just measures whether
someone is feeling something positive or
something negative arousal is measuring
whether some someone is in calm or very
ready to act very agitated and then
dominant that is measuring whether
someone is feeling dominated by the
situation or the opposite is that
someone is feeling in control of the
situation and then we also collected
some demographics of the person in the
in the picture like the gender or the
estimated age and we use crowdsourcing
for collecting all of these annotations
in particular we use the platform Amazon
Mechanical Turk and after this process
we came up with what we call the emotive
data set and which is a collection of
these images 23,000 annotated images
34,000 annotated people because for some
images we have multiple people annotated
this dataset is publicly available so if
you are interested you can download the
images and you can load download the
annotations and play with them and we
perform a lot of for statistics with the
data so and when I finished talking
about this project I'm gonna show you
the website of the project where you can
find the data and the publications that
we have I'm gonna just show you I'm
gonna show I'm going to show you a
little bit about them the deep learning
model that we developed as a baseline to
model this problem so what we did it's a
very simple model this is the
representation of the architecture so
basically
we have as input the image and we know
the location of the target person that
we are trying to recognize the emotion
of and then we have one module that is
extracting person features so it's fully
convolutional and we extract features of
the bounding box containing the person
and then we have another module which is
the context features that takes us and
input the whole image and extract also
enough using fully convolution a fully
congressional network features about the
context and then we merge these features
we have one fully connected layer and we
separate the recognition of Valon travel
and dominant and the emotion categories
and the type of loss function that we
use is regression because from our
experiments we saw that it was the best
way to model our data so these are the
type of results that we get so these are
the type of images that we get this is
recognition of anticipation and
excitement engagement and confidence in
this case this is another example of
recognition pleasure happiness an
affection in this other picture another
one pretty challenging that here is had
it recognize happiness the system but
here you don't see the face so clearly
somehow it is extracting some
information about the context and the
situation here another interesting
example where for this guy and the
recognition of emotions was like
pleasure affection and happiness but for
the other person it was like a man so it
recognized almost everything possible
and so this is showing that not all the
information is coming just from the
context but it's the combination of the
context and the person which actually
creates the output so the truth is that
this system is not working very well so
this is the first attempt in trying to
recognize emotions using not just face
but using person and situational context
so this is our first first baseline we
are progressing this project in
different directions but so far if you
are curious you can visit the website of
the project you can download or our data
you'll find our publications and soon
and we will publish the code and this is
showing world with my PT student Rana
Kosti that just graduated two weeks ago
and
of my collaborators Jose another young
okay so this is one of the projects I've
been working and related with emotions
and images I'm gonna switch to a
different modality now so I'm gonna talk
about text so another source of
information well you can get when you
can get information about the emotions
of people is text right depending on how
we feel we use different words and we
express ourselves in a different way
when we write so let me show you one
example so this is so the Red House
restaurant is a restaurant in Cambridge
in Cambridge Massachusetts in USA so if
you go to this restaurant in York you
never went to the restaurant and you
want to know how what is this restaurant
what do you do so you google this
restaurant and you get all of these
reviews right so this is one example of
a review of the Red House restaurant
okay so let's focus in a piece of this
review so here it says what a delight
terrific menu great craft cocktails and
potential and most fear of mostly locals
and college professors chatting over
dinner okay so we read this type of
reveals and from these reviews we decide
whether we want to go to the restaurant
or not
somehow we capture the idea of whether
this restaurant is good or not but it is
not saying this is a good restaurant go
there or this is not a good restaurant
don't go there okay so from this type of
information can you can you tell me if
the person that wrote this text was
feeling something positive or something
negative about the restaurant it
positive it's very clear for us it's
very easy to do right so why so what one
thing that we can think is maybe we can
develop an algorithms that do the same
so actually there are a lot of there's a
lot of research in trying to capture
sentiment from text this program is
called sentiment analysis in text and
this is one of the state-of-the-art
models it's called deep emoji it was
developed and in MIT Media Lab not an
effective computing group which is the
group I'm I'm working on it it was
developed on social machines and the
idea behind this method this is quite
simple so there's large-scale data
behind this and deep learning so
basically they took twelve hundred
million tweets containing emojis so they
selected the most common that the 64
most common emojis and they were
collecting a huge amount of of tweets
that contain these emojis and they
formulated the following problem so
taking as an input the text we want to
predict the emoji of this text and when
when so that they they have found a deep
learning architecture you can actually
the code is available and they have also
Adam online so this is a screen capture
of the demos if you if you enter the
text I showed you before you'll see this
type of output so this is the emojis
that are predicted from the from the
text and what is interesting is that you
see here like different different
intensities of the words this is because
the deep learning model has an attention
an attention layer so and it it can
capture the contribution of the
different words to this prediction and
actually it's this demo is very cool
because you can you can cross the
different words and see how the emoji is
changed when you and remove some words
so and and this is this is working
pretty well and there are other other
models that are similar to this one that
also work pretty well for text sentiment
analysis so what we were interested
actually was in the interactive
scenarios so it's very important to have
machines that can recognize emotions in
text but we think that it's also very
important that if you imagine
interactive scenario with interactive
scenario I mean a chatbot that at this
chat but is somehow aware of the emotion
of the user that is chatting with so
let's let's talk a little bit about
these chat boards and the chat pod is a
huge area of research as well but and
there are a lot of categorizations of
chat bots but one categorization that
you may you may have is goal-oriented
chat board chat bots versus open domain
chat BOTS and the difference is that
Fergal oriented the chat bots are
supposed to help the user to do some
specific tasks
for instance in a website of a store
they are supposed to help you find a
specific product that you that you need
another example would be there are some
chat boards that help you find a
restaurant in your city that matches
your expectations okay so this is goal
oriented but you have also open domain
chat boards and develop open domain chat
bodies just to chat with you in an
intelligent way Entertain You or being
able of interacting with you in an
intelligent way so let's focus in in
this open domain chat boards one thing
that that one problem that we face when
we try to train this this type of chat
bots is how can we evaluate this open
dialogue systems it's very difficult
because here you don't have like a clear
reward when you train the system it's
not like if it's wall oriented and the
task is to help the user to find a
restaurant at the end of the
conversation you know whether the user
found the restaurant yes or not right
and you can use this information to
train the chat bot but in open in open
domain you don't have like a clear loss
function so how can you evaluate them so
one option is to use automatic text
metrics you can have like a test set of
dialogues and use automatic train text
metrics or embedding distance based
metrics so that you have that your
dialogues your test set you have the
input you generate with the bot the
supposed ad output after this input and
you compare with a dialogue that you
have with this with these automatic
metrics so the problem is that there are
different different studies like this
one here and is that these automatic
metrics are embedding distance based
metrics do not match very well the
experience of the user so it's it's
actually not very well correlated so
that's why in most of the cases when
when people are working with open to my
domain chat BOTS they use human
evaluation okay
so human evaluation the the common
practice of human evaluation in this
type of dialogue systems is to use what
it's called one churn evaluation so in
one tone evaluation you have something
like that you have a context that you
give to the bot and then the walk
generates an answer so here you have
this context I think I want an iPad to
but I already have an iBook where's one
versus need and the response of the of
the chat but in these cases I'm sorry
okay if we ask a human to rate this a
specific answer in after these specific
context you may agree or not but it's
not that bad
Oh particularly because I didn't I
didn't say that but we are working with
generative generative neural network
models which means that our our BOTS do
not do not have like a large set of
predefined answers that are
grammatically correct we are generating
the answer from an embedding space from
a word embedding space so we even face
the problem of being grammatically
correct it is really challenging we are
learning to be grammatically correct
just from our training data so just the
fact of giving an answer that is
romantically correct is kind of a
success so anyway you can say okay this
is a it's more or less acceptable it
makes sense the answer I'm sorry because
the context is like I'm I don't know
what I want it's whatever but what
happens when you keep talking with this
part so the user says should I buy an
iPad 2 and the God says I'm sorry I'm
sorry I don't want to know then the user
says you are weird and then the watch
says I'm sorry ok so here we have a
problem about diversity so basically
this bot always goes to the same space
and always generate I'm sorry or
something close to I'm sorry right so if
you use just one tone evaluation and it
happens then the answer of the vote is
kind of acceptable in different contexts
you might read very well this but while
this body diversity is horrible so what
we think is that we really need
interactive evaluation for evaluating
this world it's not enough to have one's
own evaluation and the other thing that
we think is that usually these words are
evaluated about the overall quality
meaning overall how was the quality of
the chat but there are other aspects of
the conversation that are very important
for instance diversity so how
non-repetitive where the chat bot
responds or the fluency how correct well
the grammar and the sentence structure
of the chat BOTS respond so this makes
sense when you
generative models and contingency how
related to your message what a chatbot
response right you don't want to talk
about troubles and then the bot
answering about I don't know movies and
of course them but it is something you
really care about so how how emotionally
appropriate word Shadbolt responds okay
this is what we wanted to study and our
goal was to have to create a better
automatic way of measuring the capacity
of the world in in all of these aspects
okay so for that what we did is we
developed an open source platform for
multi turn evaluation here you see a
screen capture of this platform so in
this platform you can you can upload any
any dialog model that you already
trained and you can ask the user to talk
with a bot and then after the usual talk
with the bot you can ask the user to
rate the word according to the different
aspects that I mentioned okay so we use
different different types of models to
play with in this in this project and
yeah so in total we had like six
different models and I'm not gonna
explain these models but basically it's
not that important so basically we had
different models and the regularized
models so that the same models with
regularization that that we that we
imposed here in the in the in the in the
model which is so this is the original
model and then what we what we do is we
ask the board at this point to be able
of to contain information so that you
can recognize et emotion using this type
of automatic method and also the
semantic similarity so how and for that
we use some semantics some semantic
sentence embedding system well between
the models with different types of data
we used to two datasets the kernel data
set which is a movie script data set and
then the ready data set which is a data
set that we collected and these are
conversations from from them from the
reddit forum casual conversation so what
we did is human interactive evaluation
so we we asked them that the humans to
talk with our models so the three model
the basement under regularized version
model strain with Colonel dataset and
model strain with with ready dataset and
we observe that in general so in
boldface you have like them like the
best ratings so it's pretty consistent
that when you ask the user to interact
with the models they usually find that
the regularized version is better okay
but when you evaluate the traditional
metrics what you observe is that it's
more like a mess this is just the
quality so as I said before we also
found the traditional automatic methods
do not correlate very well with the
human and with the human ratings so
these are examples of the dialogues
what will it basically is with so we
have this trajectories of the of the
conversations and what we can do from
this from these conversations is to
compute different automatic metrics but
on the whole conversation automatic
metrics that we defined using some
findings in psychology on how to
characterize good how you can
characterize good conversations so
sentiment metrics so compute yeah you
can you can find all of the details of
this metrics in the paper but these are
metrics that you can compute
automatically using like this type of
emoji dip emoji algorithm all system
engagement metrics like the question
score how many questions did the user
ask when when the user was talking to
the to the ball because it's known that
the more questions you do it's it's like
a it's a it's showing engagement and the
number of words so you use longer
sentences when you feel more engaged as
well and then other semantic metrics
that you can compute automatically so
this is a total of 11 metrics that you
can compute along the conversation that
you that you and that you have okay what
you can do also is you can compute a
hybrid metric which is a linear
combination of these 11 metrics and what
we do is we try to learn these weights
here so this hybrid metrics so that you
can approximate the human rating so now
and it it worked well now what you can
do is you have this conversation of the
bottom the human you compute the hybrid
metric you have also the human
evaluation but we
that there's a high correlation so if
the what is better the the score of the
hydra-matic is better as well so as I
said the goal was to approximate the
human rating without having the human in
the loop but here we still need the
human to talk with a bot to generate
this conversation and compute all of
these metrics well the other thing that
we can do is use what we call the self
place scenario so let's remove the human
and let's put the bot to talk to itself
because if the what talks to itself we
also can generate these conversations
and we also can compute this hybrid
metric and see how well we approximate
the human ratings and this is the main
finding of our paper what we observed is
that and here is a correlation matrix
here you have all the ratings of the
human here you have the traditional
automatic matrix here are the metrics
that we defined and at the end here is
the hybrid metric and we observed that
the strongest correlation is with the
hybrid metric okay so we found a way of
approximating the human rating without
having the human in the loop so this
paper and has is very published in the
rhibs conference this year and the code
is available I was going to talk about
the applications affective computing
sorry I don't have time but as final
conclusions I I mean I think emotional
technologies are useful and have lots of
applications so these technologies are
used are being used for and for usually
experienced monitoring for M educational
purposes when you imagine online
settings in chat boards so it's it's
also very important to take care about
the emotions and also for medical
purposes and for emotional well-being
purposes and of course for a human robot
interaction we are no close of having
machines that understand emotions as
human do but we are slowly finding
solutions to specific problems that
require emotional intelligence and here
and is a lot of resources of the
projects I'm working on
thank you for your attention
thank you for a great speech my question
will be connected to with your computer
vision part what was backbone
I mean sinem specialist in an Akita was
used in your approach as a first part of
my question and the second part was it
portraying it on some close task for
example fair face face recognition oh it
was trained from scratch thank you yeah
I'm just trying to recover the
architecture of the home so yeah as you
said we didn't have enough data to train
everything from scratch this is a huge
model with a lot of parameters so what
we did is we have these two modules of
person features and context features so
we use an image net object
classification to pre-trained the person
features imagine it contains person as
one of them as one of the object
categories and we use places dataset to
train the contextual features places
dataset is a scene centric dataset and
then we we did a find you so we trained
also the last layers and we do a fine
tuning with our dataset
[Music]
BVG plays yeah so the thing is in around
30% of the images in our data set we
don't have the face completely visible
or the resolution of the face is very
small so it's very complicated to
extract these details of facial
expression but I agree with you that
this is something that we should do and
we can actually have like an additional
module right as soon as we can detect
the face and we can extract reliable
features of the face we should be able
of merging face body or whole body and
context features and that would be
better so this is one of the next steps
that we would like to
[Music]